(host)
Majestic, mysterious forms
that hold the secrets
of the universe,
or big, inscrutable rocks that
take a lot of effort to climb.
In pretty much every culture,
it's all about majesty
and mystery
when it comes to mountains.
Home to mighty deities,
sacred grounds,
and sublime phenomena,
mountains loom large
in our collective imagination.
[intro music]
Throughout history,
real and mythical mountains
have been used to discuss
both natural
and supernatural activity,
from weather
and volcanic eruptions
to everlasting youth
and ethereal beings.
But they also embody
some of our most existential
questions about life--
our position in the universe,
our spiritual doubts,
and our desire
to transcend the self.
In the earliest written records
of human history,
mountains were depicted
as sources of life.
Dating the
third millennium BCE,
tablets found at the ancient
Sumerian city of Nippur,
now Iraq, are very clear about
where the first Sumerian god
spawned the rest of his team--
"On the mountain
of heaven and earth,
Anu spawned the Anunnaki gods."
"Hursag,"
meaning mountain or hill,
is the first word
on the tablet,
making it one of the oldest
surviving written words.
On the peak of the mountain,
the Anunnaki gods
created sheep and grain
before sending them down
to mortals living on the slopes,
thus allowing human society
to flourish.
This ancient myth carries
a few key ideas
that are common
to mountain mythology.
First, the mountain acts
as the site of creation.
We see this idea unfolding
across the world.
In ancient Tibet,
for instance,
the first ruler was believed
to be a god
who descended from the sky
using a rope of woven light
to the peak
of Yarlha Shampo,
a place that would also serve
as the instrument of creation.
In the Hindu Puranas,
deities and demons tied
an enormous serpent
around the mythical
Mount Mandara,
then used the mountain
as a stick
for churning
the celestial ocean,
creating the universe itself.
Second, the mountains are also
the dwelling place of the gods.
Many cultures locate
their gods on a mountain summit.
The supreme Hindu deity Shiva
resides on Mount Kailash,
while in Greek mythology,
the principal gods
camp out on Mount Olympus.
These lofty abodes testify
to the awesome,
and frankly, sometimes
terrifying power of the divine.
In Homer's Iliad,
Zeus boasts of his power
to drag the Earth and sea
up the mountain
on a golden rope and dangle them
off the sacred peak.
The third important feature
of the Sumerian creation myth
is a vision of mountains
of a life-giving,
ever-present force
that provides both spiritual
and material sustenance.
In another Sumerian legend,
this belief is personified
in Ninhursag,
goddess of the mountains,
who produced milk
and mothered humans and animals
from her seat at the summit.
And in Tibetan mythology,
the Five Sisters
of Long Life
each occupy their own
Himalayan perch.
The resident goddess of
Mount Everest, Miyolangsangma,
is believed to be in charge
of inexhaustible giving.
This fearsome goddess
rides a tiger,
a bowl of food in one hand,
and a jewel-spitting mongoose
in the other.
This illustrates her dual role
as both a supreme nurturer
and a potentially
hazardous force,
rather like
the mountain itself.
As a mythical origin point
and lofty spiritual home
but also an enduring source
of food, land, and shelter
for those who live below,
mountains are places
where the celestial
and terrestrial collide
with awe-inspiring results.
Throughout history,
mountains were not only used
to explain the origins
and governing of the universe
but were seen as forces
of cosmic balance
in their own right.
Mythical mountains
often function as axis mundi,
or a "stabilizing axis
that extends through the Earth
"to connect its surface
with the underworld
and the heavens."
In Norse mythology,
a heavenly mountain was said
to rise at the point
where the rainbow
meets the dome of heaven,
thus acting as a force
for celestial harmony.
And in Iranian mythology,
the legendary Hara Berezaiti
was an enormous mountain
rising from the center
of the Earth
and tethered to the sky.
The stars and moon
revolved around it,
while the sun rested
behind its peak at night.
In addition
to its spiritual significance,
Hara was used
in early scientific theories
of the universe.
Many other cultures
endorsed this idea
of the mythical mountain
connecting the underground,
Earthly, and heavenly planes.
Another axis of the world,
Mount Meru, or Sumeru,
is venerated in Hindu,
Jain, and Buddhist cultures.
Hindu cosmology traces
specific mythical geographies
around Meru,
with the mountain
occupying the center
of the universe,
the city of the moon
rising in the north,
the city of the ocean god
occupying the west,
the Devas, or divinities,
dwelling in the east,
the realms of Yama,
the god of death, in the south,
and the Asanas,
or infernal demons,
lurking below.
Mount Meru was also used as
an astronomical reference point
with the pole star position
directly above its peak
tied to other heavenly bodies
by ropes of wind.
In ancient Jainian philosophy,
Meru was also used
to theorize the movement
of celestial bodies.
As these axis mundi show,
mountains were at the center
of human attempts
to explain the cosmic structure
of the universe
as well as the spiritual
significance of its realms.
Beyond the natural world,
mountains were referenced
throughout ancient architecture
that evoked the sacred
and aspirational.
Both Hindu
and Buddhist architecture
reinforces the importance
of Mount Meru
with towers and temples
evoking its sacred peak
and garden monuments
or water structures
echoing its position
in the universe.
In ancient Mesopotamia,
raised structures
called ziggurats were built
as dwelling places for deities.
These consisted
of up to seven stories
that echoed
ascending heavenly tiers
with only priests permitted
to enter their base layers
and the upper layers
reserved for the gods.
And in ancient Egypt,
the primordial mound
known as Benben
was revered for its status
as the first item
that emerged
from a watery abyss
at the beginning of the world.
This sacred mound provided
a template for the capstones
of the pyramids
and surfaces
throughout Egyptian symbols
and iconography.
In other cultures,
the worship of mountains
blends natural
and mythical phenomena.
In Hindu cosmology,
Mount Kailash is not only
the home
of the powerful deity Shiva
but the source
of the holy river Ganges,
which cascades from heaven
and pours through his hair
before continuing on
throughout the land.
Here, the mountain
is seen again
as a life-giving force
with awesome powers.
In the Diné,
or Navajo origin story,
the Creator
placed the first people
in the middle
of four mountains--
Blanca Peak, Mount Taylor,
San Francisco Peak,
and Hesperus Mountain.
Here, the mountains
delineate a homeland,
one that once stretched
over a vast space
but was protected by
these natural fortresses.
Elsewhere, the power
of the mountain
is a little more ambivalent.
In Hawaiian mythology,
the goddess Pele
commanded volcanoes.
She was believed to have
created the Hawaiian islands
and was just as feared for
her ability to cause eruptions
as she was revered for
the creation of rich new land.
The Aztecs also
honored volcanic mountains--
for example, in the form of
Popocatépetl and Iztaccíhuatl.
According to myth,
Popocatépetl and Iztaccíhuatl
were once young lovers
who were separated
when Popocatépetl
was called off to war.
Believing her beloved
had perished,
Iztaccíhuatl wasted away
from grief,
only for Popocatépetl to return
very much alive.
Distraught, he constructed
a funeral mound for Iztaccíhuatl
and lay by her side,
with their bodies eventually
transforming into mountains.
The rising smoke
was believed to signal
either their eternal
funeral torches
or their still-burning love.
While these examples venerate
and explain natural phenomena,
they also show
how people's understanding
of mountains
as natural resources
was always entwined
with ancient storytelling.
While mythical mountains
have generated
their own cosmological,
astronomical,
and geological theories,
they're also
supernatural worlds
that no human knowledge system
can account for.
In Chinese mythology,
for instance,
Mount Kunlun is
the mountainous home of deities
and immortals
that props up the sky
and forms a ladder
from heaven to Earth.
Guarded by a tiger
with nine human faces,
Kunlun is a space of abundance,
from the peaches of immortality
and grain that can grow
up to 40 feet
to the self-regenerating
cow's meat.
While these strange riches
are not easy to access,
ancient texts
promise many rewards
for climbing Mount Kunlun.
Reaching the first tier
would bestow immortality,
the second, the ability
to control wind and rain,
and the third would grant you
permanent access
to the divine realm--
not bad a reward
after a big hike.
To the east of Kunlun
is another mountainous paradise,
Mount Penglai, which is
governed by eight immortals
who can create
and destroy life at will.
In this land
of brilliant sunshine,
immortality is guaranteed
for all.
The water conveys
eternal youth,
there is no knowledge
or sickness or pain,
fruit remains ripe
all year round,
and the bowls of rice
are perpetually brimming.
Referred to as Horai
in Japanese literature,
one Shinto text
describes the mountain
as not only a paradise,
but an alien space
that stretches the limits
of human perception.
No matter your belief system,
mountains are
indisputably sublime,
which is why they remain
near universal sites
of pilgrimage.
As sites of spiritual excursion,
mountains promise
a transcendence
of earthly conditions.
From the barefoot journeys
undertaken by Catholics
to climb the rocky slopes
of Croagh Patrick--
one of the highest and holiest
mountain in Ireland--
to Hindu pilgrimages
to the sacred hill Govardhan,
home to temples
and the site of divine activity,
devotees visit and climb
mountains as a ritual
that signals spiritual
and literal ascension.
While mountain climbing is
an ostensibly secular activity,
many climbers have spoken
of a similar aspiration
to transcend the self
and reach higher plains
of understanding.
Mountains, then, are not only
enormous landmarks;
they inspire
some pretty strong feelings.
As seeds of creation
and axes of the universe,
they've helped people
narrate where they came from
and anchored our sense
of location
in an often-confusing world.
But they're also sites
of magic and mystery
in their own right.
Whether using mountains
to track the movements of stars,
curry favor with the gods,
or explain seismic shifts,
it's clear that mountains have
always driven our imaginations
to new heights.
History lovers,
we need to tell you
about a new series from PBS
called "The Bigger Picture."
Hosted by
Professor Vincent Brown,
it's a show that examines
famous photographs
and unpacks the
historical context around them.
In doing so, we reveal
what these photos can tell us
about our history, but also
how we view ourselves.
Check out the first episode
at the link in the description
and head to
the PBS YouTube channel
to see it yourself.
Tell them "Fate & Fabled"
sent you.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.